je suis essoufflé
à pied
ça va bien je suis un peu
étages à pied
les propriétaires l'ami un ascenseur il
habitait aussi
dis donc
ici non
non
on a commencé avec Jean-Pierre Coffe
et on a parlé de vin déjà et il m'a mis
de 20 en tête pour le restant de la
soirée
quoi la tienne ça me fait plaisir de te
voir la dernière fois que je t'ai vu je
t'avais obligé à dire du bien du roi
d'Espagne il t'avait dit oui c'est vrai
il est quand même pas mal tu t'es
souvenir des seins je me souviens
attends moi le roi d'Espagne pas rien
pour moi ah oui c'est important c'est un
bonbon
mais du bien des gentillesse
antérieure
donne
très vieux aux gens qui pensait qu'il
était français
mais tu sais que c'est bien parce qu'il
est arrivé à réconcilier
aussi bien Carillo que arabal après tout
ce que tu as fait je trouve ça pas mal
politique
l'histoire des
échecs là tu as vu casse pas off contre
alors contribble là
avant tu penses qu'il est nul
j'étais petit
à la place de prendre des types
intéressants comme molotiller comme au
cas où il prend un petit comme ça
vraiment que c'est le mieux qui peut
faire puisque dans l'histoire de
l'humanité on a toujours trouvé des
choses comme ça c'est un qui est le
meilleur musicien un jour qui sort le
meilleur peintre de saveur qui sauvent
pas bien
c'est le roi cabinet
il a lui il a il est incapable de bien
jouer tu vois
alors lorsqu'on fait un coup il s'en va
au cabinet c'est permis par la loi ici
que
tu crois qu'ils ont des émetteurs non
là
c'est pour ça que et le système
donc on joue aux échecs
oui
comment tu vis là tu viens enfermer ici
ah bon
ici alors
c'est un petit musée ici c'est quoi
c'est ton petit musée personnels
ils sont beaux ces tableaux
avec Mussolini j'avais jamais vu
celui-là Mussolini Hitler Franco c'est
un bloc qui est fait faire
les croquis
m'a dit un truc génial m'a dit
toute la vie c'est mieux avec un coup
dans le nez mais personne n'ose le dire
c'est un grand philosophe
lui il a pas accepté il y a beaucoup à
la maison
mais comment il était pas très
intelligent il était il était horrifié
parce que
j'avais fait un film qui s'appelle viva
la muerte il est beau hein
et ça c'est beau ces boîtes alors le
jour on a vu on était on est allé voir
des gens qui faisaient ça on est allé
voir des artistes
c'est pas loin oui
c'est lié c'est très lié
je pense ça c'est Magritte ça se fera un
chrétienne les ministres de la Culture
ça c'est facile
maintenant c'est un acte
si on peut dire que c'est drôle parce
que il est devenu
à l'époque il était comme moi il était
un type drôle
mais ça c'est signé pour lui maintenant
et ça aussi c'est un livre
ça c'est encore un livre mais je l'ai
pas ouvert encore il vient d'arriver
de la Mer Morte
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu